first for those who don't know what are
you I am assistant a large language
model trained by open AI Chad GPT chat
GPT chat GPT on Monday Microsoft
announced a multi-year multi-billion
dollar investment in open AI openai has
devolved from being an altruistic
non-profit to being a big Texas pool
virtually everyone from Microsoft and
Google to Apple and Samsung want to
create their own version of chat GPT or
even buy out chat GPT itself this really
isn't that surprising given the Roaring
launch of chat GPT despite being out for
just a few months chat GPT is already
pulling into as much search interest as
a Google Drive and six times more search
interest than Siri but while these
numbers are impressive they're also
quite worrisome especially when you
consider the winning morals and ethics
behind this technology you see it it's
not just a big Tech that has been
tainting the wholesome Ambitions of
openai open AI themselves have slowly
trended in the direction of profit and
the corporate greed as opposed to
research and innovation in in fact this
is one of the main reasons that Elon
Musk one of the firm's Founders and the
earliest Advocates quit the company five
years ago actually his parting message
was that he didn't agree with what the
firm wanted to do more recently he has
doubled down on this dance he says that
the entire vision of openai was to
create a non-profit open source
competitor to Google hence the name open
AI but now open AI has become a closed
Source maximum profit company that's
effectively controlled by Microsoft
despite this the general public has
embraced chat GPT with open arms its
ability to write School essays and the
Google level code has seemingly
overshadowed its moral and ethical
shortcomings at this rate it's just a
matter of time onto an AI based search
becomes a necessity as opposed to a
luxury which will simply give big tech
companies and new AI Superstars even
more control over our daily lives and
Society at large this becomes even more
sketchy when you consider that certain
companies near Lincoln Elon Musk want to
put AI powered chips directly into our
brains so here's the story of how openai
lost their moral compass in a record of
time and its frightening implications
for the future of AI
foreign
taking a look back openai didn't just
start with good intentions they started
with altruistic intentions back in the
mid-2010s AI was an open Frontier with
little competition the best AI had to
offer was a voice assistance that
struggled to answer even the most basic
questions but a couple of influential
people wanted to change this they wanted
to create a new platform that was
focused on AI research and development
and unlike the existing options they
wanted this platform to not be motivated
by money ironically all of the people
behind this effort were already
extraordinarily Rich this included the
likes of Elon Musk Peter Theo and Reed
Hoffman there were also a few
institutions involved including Amazon
web services Infosys and Y combinator
research but at the same time these
people and entities being rich was kind
of a good thing for one given their
extreme wealth you would think that they
wouldn't need more so they get to stick
to keeping open AI non-profit and to it
they could contribute large sums of
money to actually make this endeavor
well funded and viable looking back we
can confirm that they did at least stick
to the second point the company itself
was founded with a 1 billion dollars
worth of funding and according to open
ai's own blog they only expected to
spend a tiny fraction of this over the
next few years but let's just say that
it didn't take long for things to get
out of hand since then openai has had to
raise a total of 11 billion dollars for
perspective openai's funding alone is
nearly worth the entire market cap of a
Domino's Pizza one of the first problems
that the openai team faced was actually
attracting talent for decades Elon had
relied on recruiting truly passionate
Engineers to drive forward Tesla and
SpaceX these Engineers joined these
companies out of passion as opposed to
the money but Elon couldn't just use the
same tactics with open an AI here's the
thing when it comes to rockets and space
engineers have a very limited number of
choices they can either join NASA
defense contractors or SpaceX so
convincing them to join SpaceX wasn't
exactly difficult but with AI Engineers
had the option to join basically at any
big tech company that they wanted to so
they weren't exactly jumping up and down
with excitement trying to join a
non-profit it was actually quite the
opposite sure openai might have had nice
intentions but they were by no means the
only ones with cool projects so there
was no need for these highly talented
Engineers to settle for a substantially
lower salary just to work for open AI if
anything open AI had to how to pay
Google Amazon and apple to get Engineers
to ditch the safety and stability of
these companies and this was a much
easier said than done the primary reason
that these companies are able to pay so
much is because much of their
compensation packages are derived from
stock but open AI stock well that was
useless they were a non-profit so openai
had to pull on Netflix and offer all
cash compensations but this depleted the
funding quite rapidly you see we're not
talking about salaries of 200 000 or
even three hundred thousand dollars
we're talking about a median
compensation of nine hundred thousand
dollars for software Engineers I at that
rate just 100 Engineers would burn at 90
million dollars at every single year
open AI was quickly becoming a full on
charity as they lost money hand over
fist and it was just a matter of time
until they had to do something
it wasn't just a payroll that was
weighing down open AI either it turns
out that AI research in general is just
extraordinarily expensive open AI would
figure this out firsthand as they Dove
head first into AI development their
first project was called open AI Gem and
this was a relatively tame Endeavor
essentially they had created a
playground for AI enthusiasts around the
world to compete on these enthusiasts
had to develop AI algorithms that could
beat Atari games board games and other
2D and 3D simulations and these
enthusiasts would be ranked on a
leaderboard based on how versatile and
robust their algorithms were essentially
open AI was leveraging the competitive
side of Engineers to research and
develop AI for free their second project
Universe very much relied on this same
idea instead of developing the AI
themselves openai opted to develop a
platform that could let anyone or at
least anyone with Advanced coding
knowledge to test algorithms on the most
popular games and website
but they couldn't rely on external
sources forever eventually they had to
start developing their own AI but this
was accompanied by Insane expenses
almost instantaneously here's the thing
how do you train an AI well the answer
is by processing a ridiculous amount of
possibilities and outcomes which
requires a ludicrous amount of
infrastructure take open ai's Dota 2 bot
for example to train the spot openai had
to let the AI play against itself for a
simulated 10 000 years to simulate this
many years open AI had to use 256 Nvidia
gpus and 128 000 CPU cores which they
ironically rented from Google
but even all of that was only able to
simulate 180 years worth of gameplay
every day meaning that they had to run
the setup for 56 days just to complete
initial training of the bond at that
rate I don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that open ai's Cloud Computing
expenses alone would end up being 7.9
million dollars in 2017. it was becoming
abundantly clear that this whole
non-profit benefit Humanity thing just
wasn't gonna work company insiders were
starting to propose the idea of making
openai a for-profit Endeavor being
for-profit and Advantage Humanity
weren't mutually exclusive right they
could still stick to their altruistic
intentions but leverage all of their
financial benefits that come from the
world of business and especially Venture
Capital while this sounded good in
theory Elon Musk knew that this wouldn't
never play out in the way that the team
was hoping the second that profit
incentive was introduced it was just a
matter of time under the company became
a soulless organization Ilana already
had plenty of for-profit AI Endeavors in
his portfolio openai was designed to be
something different but now that it too
was becoming the same thing Elon decided
that it was time to step away at least
now he wouldn't have to compete against
himself for AI Talent shortly after his
departure openai would complete the
transition to becoming a for-profit
company
foreign
technically open AI isn't a full-on
for-profit company it's actually a
capped for-profit company but this
doesn't really mean much in the case of
open AI capped profit simply means that
no investor is allowed to profit more
than 100x which is an insanely generous
limit even if you had invested in apple
right when the iPhone was announced back
in 2007 you'd only have been up 40x even
at the peak so it's safe to say that
investors won't have to worry about open
AIS profit cap anytime soon almost
immediately after openai transitioned to
being for-profit Microsoft got involved
Microsoft initially invested one billion
dollars into open AI in mid-2019 and
unsurprisingly open AI would announce
their new commercial intentions in this
same press release but if they wanted to
pursue the Commercial Avenue they first
needed a commercially viable product
leading them to revisit one of their old
research papers
improving language understanding by
generative pre-training or GPT initially
this was just a relatively small project
that was fueled by the contents of 7 000
books but over time they had improved
the system to rely on an 8 million
website with 1.5 billion parameters this
was actually years ago but the reason
that you probably didn't know about this
was because openai decided to not
release GPT to the public they felt that
the system could easily be used for
nefarious purposes like writing scam
emails and generating fake news but
these worries quickly evaporated away
once Microsoft got involved from
Microsoft's perspective this was their
big shot at taking on Google and they
weren't gonna let a couple of fake
emails get in their way so they gave the
green light for developing a
commercially viable version of gbt and
it gave open AI resources that they
could previously only dream of they gave
them access to a supercomputer with 2
285 000 CPU cores and 10 000 gpus this
was the fifth most powerful computer in
the entire world you can't just get
access to these computers by paying to
get access to such computers you need
these Mega corporations to be on your
side and Microsoft was squarely on open
AI Side open AI was able to use this
computer to process 45 terabytes of Text
data which translated to a whopping 175
billion parameters open AI would go
ahead and develop a chat box that could
communicate with this gpt3 Ai and this
led to the creation of chatgpt as we
know it today but that's nothing in
comparison to what openai is working on
right now you know how gpt3 was based on
175 billion parameters well gpt4 is
speculated to be based on 100 trillion
parameters and it may be launched by the
end of this year as you can see open AI
is just getting started but big Tech
already has a tight grip on the company
and you can be sure that they will
monetize anything and everything that
this company will ever be
foreign
it's easy to see why open AI turned to
the dark side they tried to go the open
source route and Advance AI research and
development but the reality is that even
the richest people in the world tend to
fund this project this Vision can only
be funded by corporate levels of wealth
in the hundreds of billions but don't be
fooled though these companies aren't
investing hundreds of billions out of
the goodness of their hearts they're
well aware that the next Frontier is AI
and machine learning and they want to
maximize the chances that they're the
winners of that Frontier as well in the
meantime while it may seem like we're
getting all of these cool products for
free it's just a matter of time until
there is a catch whether that be simple
data collection or control over our
entire lives either way though open AI
becoming the villain is just an
inevitability but that's just what I
think are you excited or scared for the
future of AI comment that down below
also drop a like if you wished that the
original openai had come to fruition and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community suggestivity ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions also answered until then I'm
Hari and Aussie guys on the next one
foreign